everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend
I want you to me porky he's a spool yes
yeah I know
porky is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him woody we
have a situation I am NOT a toy I was
they pursued salad maybe chili and then
the trash but we've gotta get forking
over it
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on bow bow hi my name is Gabby
Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff Woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Bonnie we have to
find totally - but what would he do jump
out of a moving vehicle let's go hey you
gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this loss toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can
because you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're coming home
on my way whatever Lewis sanity
lose their toys everyday I was made to
help the child I don't remember it being
this hard wait somebody's whispering in
your ear
[Music]
everyone we're going on a road trip
vacation
[Music]
all right Sheriff let's do this astro
boy come on help me get out of here
handle no not this one are you kidding
it's a commercial it's not just one I
have all of them I have all the
questions
kaboom rated G you're kidding me he said
that to your face to my face and then
what happens I get real close right I'm
like I don't care which Cabbage Patch
you're from Oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
you see the new movie trailer for what
you ain't see it what what is it my
donkey what they're making another Toy
Story movie no I thought those movies
were done dog they made three movies did
make three movies this is number four
toy stories - yeah what about Buzz
Lightyear stuff I am Buzz Lightyear
Space Ranger what is like to infinity
and your mom that's not right you sure
no that's not right I'm pretty sure
that's it let me show you to insanity
and blonde what do you even know -
immunity and respond
hey guys you got it all wrong it's to
infinity and beyond go to infinity
dummies it's impossible beyond and
finish nothing about science
[Music]
ok class crafts time
[Music]
we got this kindergarten saying under
control
I can't believe talking to a spork
everyone body made a friend in class no
no she literally made a new friend I
want you to meet four key shoots and
ladders rated G
[Music]
angel hair and ice cream castle
[Music]
and everywhere
I looked across up where
but now
we block the Sun hey ray
so
these are
look
[Music]
No
Oh
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey somebody get down before home
tonight out
[Music]
you've got red wow this place is amazing
why's a buzz gonna meet us here he must
be held up somewhere hey up here ask our
boy
if you think you can take our top prize
spot your room dead wrong help me get
out of here
[Music]
[Music]